what is the euro area also known as the
euro zone it is made up of the EU member
states that have adopted the euro as
their currency the euro was first
introduced in 1999 as an accounting
currency banknotes and coins followed in
2002 the euro is now the currency of
over three hundred and thirty seven
million EU citizens it is also a major
trading currency outside the EU most EU
member states are in the euro area the
UK and Denmark have opted out while
others have yet to fulfill conditions
for entry to join the Euro countries
have to meet economic and legal
conditions known as the Maastricht
convergence criteria only then will the
Commission the Parliament and the
central bank consider a country's
request to join the euro area the
council must take the final decision
through a vote ministers from the euro
area member states work together in an
informal body called the Euro group the
Euro group is chaired by a president
elected by its members for two and a
half years the president also represents
the euro area at international level the
Euro group ensures that euro area
countries closely coordinate their
economic and budgetary policies it also
prepares the euro summit meetings that
bring together heads of state or
government of the euro area countries
they provide strategic guidelines for
euro area economic policy find out all
you want to know about the euro area and
much more on Concilium euro / Ian
[Music]